[Music]
on this Sunday night celebrating
Canada's indigenous communities a day to
honor and reflect we are not more likely
to be criminals
we're just more likely to be over police
as an investigation continues into how
healthcare workers treat First Nations
in the ER the chair of a Canadian
University resigns over controversial
tweets plus Trump boasted he'd be giving
a campaign speech to a million but the
crowds fell flat and crossing the stage
in different ways to mark the important
milestone of graduation
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us today Canadians honor this country's
indigenous community this year there is
a heightened focus on the systemic
racism and inequalities faced by First
Nations people every day including
recent allegations that have come to
surface accusing health care workers in
BC of discriminating against indigenous
patients with a game as Abigail Beeman
reports many in the community hope
Canadians are getting the picture and
will push for change my sisters I danced
for you a powerful three and a half
minutes created by willow Frances she's
just 16 it was a school project her
teacher encouraged her to post publicly
now Francis hopes it spreads awareness
about missing and murdered indigenous
women on this national indigenous
peoples day systemic racism is in
sharper focus not far from where the
Francis's live
Rodney Levi was killed by police earlier
this month like you're not sure like
should I call the cops while in British
Columbia this price is right game is is
so offensive and and just so incredibly
disgusting The Price is Right
allegedly played by BC emergency room
staff to guess the blood alcohol level
of patients particularly indigenous ones
to doctors the brilliant they've done so
much learning and if they can't even
unpack and understand the implications
of their behavior how are we going to
expect everybody to have these
understandings looking indigenous isn't
isn't an option for people when they
wake up in the morning so to face that
kind of treatment and stigma just what
people look at your face can you imagine
how that feels the chair of indigenous
studies at the University of Winnipeg
says her research shows hospitals and
police stations are some of the worst
places in terms of indigenous racism
but she is hopeful in this moment the
impact of the black lives matter
movement means more Canadians are paying
attention Canadians need to be called
out for their racism whether they're
aware of that racism or not there is
systemic discrimination it's been more
than a year since the National inquiry
into missing and murdered indigenous
women and girls delivered its final
report but the government has yet to act
blaming cope at 19 we're not going to
let this play but we're not going to
allow it to do to collect dust the
pandemic did force most indigenous
peoples Day events online but no matter
the form everyone agrees talking about
racism and giving a voice to those
impacted is so important today and every
day
Abigail Beeman Global News Ottawa
Ontario police watchdog is investigating
an officer-involved shooting in
Mississauga that killed a 62 year old
man his family says he had schizophrenia
and wasn't a harm to anyone but himself
the situation is again raising serious
questions about whether officers are
adequately trained to deal with mental
health emergencies work in Campbell
reports I'm here I say you kill my
friends family and supporters of a jazz
Chowdhury want to know what happened to
him Saturday night the 62 year old was
shot and killed in his home by Peel
Region police family says Chantry lived
with a mental illness and had called 911
when they became concerned he stopped
taking prescribed medication when police
arrived they say Chowdhury barricaded
himself in his apartments family members
say police wouldn't allow them to help
with the situation there was no
opportunity given there was no way of
trying to save his life
video captured at the scene and verified
by family members shows officers in
tactical gear entering Choudhary's
apartment through the balcony entrance
all well family members stood by
concerned because they say Choudhary
didn't speak English Pio police say they
were told Chowdhury had access to
weapons and he was a danger to himself
according to Ontario's police watchdog
police discharged a Taser fired plastic
projectiles and when those had no effect
an officer shot the man the SIU says a
knife was found at the scene and it has
invoked its mandates this clearly
insanity doing the same thing and
expecting different on the heels of
nationwide protests calling for reform
experts say this is another example last
year why social workers need to be
deployed in these circumstances not
police they'll respond with the tools at
hand which are handcuffs guns tasers and
rubber bullets right they are not
equipped with a social and psychological
knowledge to deal with mental illness
family members and the Muslim community
say an investigation doesn't go far
enough and they want a public inquiry it
is clear that the police did very little
to de-escalate this situation we have no
faith in an investigation that is
conducted by the SIU as the community
rallies behind the Chowdhury family the
62 year old is being remembered as a
selfless man this was the most genuine
beautiful soul that we knew there's
little doubt friends and family will be
pushing for more accountability in the
coming days
Chad Ruiz on Topsy is scheduled for
Monday in Toronto Robin Morgan Campbell
in Mississauga Ontario the chair of the
University of British Columbia's Board
of Governors has resigned a student
group noticed that Michael Kornberg
liked a tweet linking the black lives
matter movement to Hitler's paramilitary
wing and a series of other racist tweets
Catherine Hart reports
UBC is one of the most respected
universities in Canada and around the
world but now it's dealing with a
scandal involving its Board of Governors
which manages the school's 2.3 billion
dollar operating budget the chair forced
to resign because his social media
activity included liking hateful racist
tweets I think it's a position of a
leadership at the University it's
incumbent upon him to reflect community
values Michael Coren Berg was an adjunct
professor at UBC zallard School of Law
for 24 years in 2016 he was appointed to
the University's Board of Governors then
elected chair in 2018 it all ended after
the group students against bigotry
posted photos from his Twitter account
they showed he had liked tweets praising
US president Trump's references to
protesters as violent looters and a
conspiracy theory comparing black lives
matter protests to Adolf Hitler's
paramilitary tactics
UBC's Board of Governors has issued a
statement saying that it has zero
tolerance for racism adding that it is
committed to addressing systemic racism
Kornberg has since tweeted an apology
saying I owe all students faculty and
staff and all those who stand against
all forms of discrimination an apology I
do so with all my heart I think it's
good that he's resigned and took the
responsibility because no one like that
should be the head of any form of
university also condemning the tweets B
C's advanced education minister as UBC
deals with the troubling circumstances
surrounding the resignation of Michael
Kornberg his position as chair is being
filled temporarily by another board
member Catherine Urquhart Global News
Vancouver US president Donald Trump
officially kicked off his reelection
campaign with an eyebrow raising speech
but it was in front of a much smaller
crowd than he hoped for he'll face more
controversy in the week ahead with
former national security adviser John
Bolton's new tell-all books set to be
released Tuesday Jennifer Johnson
reports US President Donald Trump back
on the campaign trail for the first time
in over
three months trying to rally his base as
his poll numbers continue to sing in his
one hour 40 minutes speech the president
made several controversial remarks
including this one about the new
coronavirus it's a disease without
question has more names I can be
White House officials had previously
denied using this offensive term back in
March in front of a Chinese American
journalist at the rally people stood
shoulder-to-shoulder few wearing masks
as the rates of Kovach 19 reached record
levels in Oklahoma and several other
states president blaming the increase on
more testing White House officials now
say the president said that in jest
there were plenty of empty seats despite
the president's claim of over a million
RSVPs Trump opponents apparently took to
social media in an effort to keep seats
empty I recommend that all of those of
us that want to see this 19 thousand
seat auditorium barely filled or
completely empty don't reserve tickets
now but Trump blame black lives matter
protesters for keeping rally goers away
as he blasted opponent Joe Biden's
record on racial injustice the president
now faces another threat to his
reelection bombshell allegations from
his former national security adviser
John Bolton in an exclusive interview
with ABC News Bolton says his new book
details 17 months working for what he
describes as a corrupt and reckless
leader I don't think he's fit for office
I don't think he has the confidence to
carry out the job there really isn't any
guiding principle that I was able to
discern other than what's good for
Donald Trump's re-election the Justice
Department has been trying to block the
books Tuesday release or prevent any
profits from going to Bolton the
tell-all book is likely to draw more
intense scrutiny on President Trump as
he fights to stay in the White House for
four more years Jennifer Johnson Global
News Washington
British police are calling a stabbing
rampage that killed three people a
terrorist attack it happened last night
in the town of Redding just west of
London
witnesses say a man began attacking
people in a park police managed to
apprehend the suspect British media are
reporting the 25 year old suspect was
known by UK intelligence but never met
the criteria for a full investigation
well I'm appalled and sickened that
people should lose their lives in this
way if there are changes that need to be
made to our legal system to stop such
events happening again we will not
hesitate to take that action police
believe the suspect was working alone he
has been identified as an asylum seeker
from Libya still ahead is the Canada
emergency response benefit discouraging
Canadians from returning to work
Manitoba is easing into phase 3 of its
reopening plan recording only two new
cases of Cova 19 yesterday restaurants
and bars can go back to full capacity
but tables still need to be 2 metres
apart childcare centers and retail
stores can return to normal people
arriving from other western provinces
northern territories and northwestern
Ontario no longer have to self isolate
for 14 days the easing of restrictions
is good news for Canadian businesses but
some are facing a new problem
the Canada emergency response benefit or
cerb is meant to tide over Canadians who
can't work because of the pandemic but
as Nadia Stewart explains it's become a
disincentive for some employees to
return to the job a sip suwari says it
took years to build the team at Afghan
kitchen but Cove at 19 forced the layoff
of nearly 20 staffers leaving the owners
working around the clock we're here
every single day I work seven days a
week almost like sometimes 16 to 20
hours to make sure that we survive
through the pandemic now that the
restaurant can't reopen suwari says
they're facing a new challenge like many
other small businesses they're
struggling to lure their staff back to
work there's no easy answer a lot of
people lost their job
when the economy shut down some people
are opting to stay home and they have
their own reason but yes it has been
very challenging to bring some of our
staff back the Canada Emergency Response
benefit was meant to support workers
who'd lost their job because of the
pandemic it's not clear how many people
are opting to continue receiving the
benefits though they can return to work
we certainly have members who are
telling us that when they call their
workers and ask them to come back the
worker says you know I'm good my bills
are being paid I'm just gonna take the
rest of the summer off see how things go
and you may call in the fall the
Canadian Federation of Independent
Business as Ottawa is looking to
introduce new guidelines among them if
an employee is called back their
benefits would end and requiring people
receiving the funds to be available and
looking for work as is the case with the
eye moving forward with our bill would
give us further measures to encourage
people and to you know make sure that
people were taking work when it came up
I believe they really need to look at
that minimum 1,000 trash fault and make
some adjustments to help out not only
the families but the small businesses as
well both suwari and Kelly acknowledged
some workers are unable to return to
work because of health concerns or they
cannot find reliable childcare the hope
government will find the right balance
between Canada's cash-strapped
households and small businesses nadya
terekhova news tourism is key to Spain's
economy which accounts for 12% of the
country's GDP that's why Spain is now
opening its borders to European tourists
the European visitors will be allowed to
enter the country without needing to
quarantine for 14 days but social
distancing restrictions are still in
place and masks are required in shops
and on public transportation
Spain reported more than two hundred and
forty six thousand cases of Cova 19 and
over 28 thousand deaths still ahead
remembering Canada's role in the korean
war on its 70th anniversary
a ceremony was held in the nation's
capital today to mark the 70th
anniversary of the Korean War outside
the South Korean embassy in Ottawa just
a handful of veterans and dignitaries
gathered because of the Cova 19 pandemic
the war between Soviet backed communists
in the north and the american-backed
democratic government in the south
broke out on June 25th 1950 more than
26,000 canadians volunteered to serve
during the three-year conflict five
hundred and sixteen of them never came
home making it the third bloodiest war
in Canadian military history it ended
with the signing of an armistice
agreement in July 1953 but it wasn't a
peace treaty the two Koreas are
technically still at war in the war
against Cova nineteen we are all
changing our behavior social distancing
is now part of our vernacular
we're told where we can go where to
stand and think about those taped arrows
on the ground as our my Clicquot tour is
here to tell us that's helping some
industries thrive Mike well that's right
Rob and you can hardly go anywhere these
days without seeing those floor decals
directing you where to go we're telling
you where to stand same goes for
plexiglass dividers keeping you and the
frontline worker protected from each
other as you can imagine someone has to
make those things at the start of this
pandemic it was such a run on plexiglass
that some companies couldn't get their
hands on enough material the things have
leveled off a bit now but one glass
company I spoke with said they think
this pandemic has forced a rethink of
how customers will interact with
businesses meaning there will be glass
dividers pretty much everywhere the same
goes for those decals it's likely
physical distancing will be important
for a long time those floor stickers
will be needed to keep us two metres
apart
now one Ottawa man is betting big on
masks he thinks those surgical masks
will be a mainstay so he imported a mask
making machine from China so that people
in this country will stop buying masks
from that country not gonna lie it's
probably one of the scariest business
ideas if I've ever come
with our hope is is that Canadians and
governments and businesses will support
local and if our material and our
finished product is a comparable price
to what they were paying before that
they'll consider swapping over to a
Canadian company to buy that product I
was going to offer more colors than just
the basic blue and he's hoping to
partner with companies because he can
print corporate logos on those masks and
he believes we will need them for months
or even years to come Robin Mike look at
Oren Ottawa thanks Mike and the new
reality airs tonight at 7 p.m. right
here on global up next graduation
improvisation the class of 2020 gets
creative in the pandemic Prince William
is having an especially good day he's
celebrating both Father's Day and his
38th birthday to mark the occasion the
royal family has released new family
photos of William having a little fun
with his children the Duke and Duchess
of Cambridge haven't forgotten their own
dads on Father's Day
of course tweeting both Prince Charles
and Michael Middleton a special greeting
Father's Day isn't the only celebration
that looks a little different in 2020
this time of year is usually filled with
graduation parties but those aren't
allowed right now because of the
pandemic it's been hard on grads but as
Mike drily explains they've come up with
some rad ways to mark the milestone what
better way to say high school grads are
moving on up in their education than
ride on a ski lift
jet ski graduation or what about heading
off into the open ocean on a jet ski
life is kind of like that after all
isn't it visual metaphors aside
graduation is a pretty big deal and with
20/20 putting the kibosh on parties
students about to get creative to keep
their day special in Calgary they acted
like they'd won the Stanley Cup and up
the highway in Edmonton the ceremony was
socially distant and responsible I wish
I could be a bit more like together but
I mean this is the best we can get it
was good but not nearly as much fun as
this dancing student clearly wanted it
to be even at the US West Point Academy
graduates at physically distant from one
another with military precision threw
their hats up in the air and then threw
the rules at the door and hugged each
other every ceremony has been unique in
its own way for students desperate for
normalcy there's like no like ceremony
for like graduation it's like you can't
really get to walk across the stage and
make like that statement you know like
I'm finishing a gun and that holds extra
weight in this Toronto neighborhood that
carries a stigma of guns and crime it's
why every year community leaders take to
the streets music and a parade for every
age elementary through high school
graduating really is a form of
resilience and it really does
demonstrate a huge accomplishment for
our young people
so grads couldn't gather on mass
anywhere
and while ceremonies and proms were
missed what was organized in their stead
will likely leave a more lasting
impression microlight Global News
Toronto and that is global national for
this Sunday I'm Robin Gill we leave you
tonight on this first full day of summer
with a rare sight an annual solar
eclipse also known as a Ring of Fire it
darkened the skies across parts of Asia
and Africa as the Northern Hemisphere's
summer solstice took place the last time
these two events coincided was 1982 and
it won't happen again until the year
2030 nine we hope you're enjoying the
longest day of the year
good night
[Music]
you